[Music]
in 1948 one family-owned business
started making sake in western japan
today it's one of the most famous sake
brands
asahi shuzo which makes dasai is the
biggest premium sake brewer in the world
and now it wants to expand from here in
the mountains of yamaguchi to new york
so we gotta look inside to see exactly
what it takes to make a bottle
first stop prepping the rice
what makes a sake premium comes down to
how much of a grain of rice is used
dassai 23 for example uses rice that's
polished down to just 23 percent of its
original size which is what experts say
give it a more delicate and fragrant
taste
next we head to the brewery and get an
air shower before entering for this next
process
washing and soaking
and yes this takes time and manpower
since it's all done by hand
this way they can precisely control and
adjust just how much water the rice
absorbs
third step is the steamer
this is essentially where rice gets
cooked it gets poured into these big
pots and then the process of digging
them out begins
then it gets cooled down in smaller
batches
step 4 making koji
this is what's known as the heart of
sake crafting koji is cooked rice onto
which a mold has been propagated it
helps convert starch in the rice into
fermentable sugar
but this process looks and sounds more
like a ritual
after that comes fermentation
this is done at a low temperature for a
long time and you start seeing these
bubbles
the barrels are mixed by hand using a
long panel
and data is collected throughout the
process to keep an eye on each one
then it's on to pressing and filtering
asahi shuzo uses a centrifuge machine
for this to separate the sake from the
mash
last but not least is bottling
the sake is stored raw for it to
naturally sweeten before getting bottled
up and then shipped out to the world
the current ceo of the fourth generation
family business wants to recreate all of
these steps in the us
you're opening your first sake brewery
outside
the sake made at the new york sakagura
is called dassai blue and the hope is
that it will not only become a rival to
but surpass the original
[Music]
you